[Musik]
die fidschi inseln sind ja gastgeber
hier bei der weltklimakonferenz sind
aber auch vom untergang bedroht durch
den steigenden meeresspiegel sollte man
sich umbenennen in fidschi inseln einig
wer denn den nicht wie inseln weil wir
gehen an stellen nicht mit den menschen
um die dort leben also einfach nur die
realität abgebildet mit einem neuen
namen
ich finde das sollte man zu lassen indem
es ist auch nicht so bald weg inseln
auch so würde ich sie nicht nennen sie
haben ja in den letzten vier jahren als
umweltministerin ehrgeizige ziele gehabt
sind aber auch von der eigenen partei
immer ausgebremst worden
denkt man sich ja auch manchmal hätte
ich auch zu hause bleiben können so doku
spielen der doku maria nicht dazu habe
ich ehrlich gesagt keine zeit oder
vielleicht auch keine geduld ja ich bin
natürlich von unterschiedlichen tritt
aber im gegensatz zum klimawandel ist
das wenigste was sie lösen könnten
das könnte ich meine umweltministerin
wie muss immer voranschreiten und
übrigen sie weiß genau wie dies jetzt
noch nicht erkannt haben die werden mit
zeitverzögerung auch erkennen sind sie
sicher auch was seine linda zum beispiel
angeht was andere was ja in jinan
scheuer diese liste ist lang
ich bin nicht bei allen ganz sicher aber
ich sage mal eine grundausstattung von
intelligenz traue ich den allen auch zu
[Musik]
man könnte übrigens sehr viel mehr
menschen satt bekommen wenn man nicht so
viel fleisch essen würde sondern wenn
man auch mehr auf vegetarische kost
umsteigen würde aber die schmeckt ja oft
nicht allen schmeckte was so ordentlich
zubereitete und genauso bei fleisch ich
meine vielleicht auch nicht schmecken
deine scheiße der macht ist gehören sich
jetzt zum russischen pavillon auch dazu
wir haben den russischen block mit
unterstützt und vorbereitet wenn man das
mal aus klima technischer sicht
betrachtet muss man sich da jetzt als
russe nicht sagen h
das mit der krim war doch blöd weil es
ist ja eine insel und die wird
irgendwann untergehen durch den
klimawandel mal lieber was anderes
annektieren sollen ja erst mal sehe ich
das nicht als eine extreme aber das ist
jetzt sage ich mal ein anderes thema die
auswirkungen die bemerken wir auch in
russland
andere länder wie zum beispiel fidschi
da wären die auswirkungen wahrscheinlich
früher zu spüren sein und deshalb ist
wahr dass auch kalkül dass man sich für
die grimme entschieden hat mich für die
fidschi inseln wie gesagt gelassen weil
diese politischen spekulationen hier aus
dem raum meinen sie die erde wäre schon
gerettet wenn die co2 werte so sinken
würden wie die wahlergebnisse der spd
die co2 werte müssen jedenfalls am
besten sinken ja erstmal stagnieren was
sie seit drei jahren tun nicht
ausweichen
das war es von der klimakonferenz und
jetzt bin ich bei der anti
klimakonferenz oder wie man im volksmund
sagt flughafen was sagen sie ihren
enkeln wenn diese irgendwann vielleicht
mal fragen warum habe ich team und
leuchtet im dunkeln
dann sage ich dann immer früher nicht
genug darauf geachtet haben sie da was
zu sagen welche klimakonferenz in bonn
damit trifft sie das ja vom land gibt es
auch weil dann nicht mehr unter wasser
liegen sie jetzt irgendwo hin aber dann
fliegen sie ihr eigenes land zugrunde
ja ich weiß das ja nicht ich laufe immer
hinter die vorher haben wir noch ein
kurzes rollenspiel und zwar sie sind
jetzt jemand der gleich einen flug nimmt
also sie sind sie und ich bin ein eisbär
ein bisschen heißt ja ich kann sie nicht
hören ich bin tot
wie finden sie es dass air berlin die
erste klimaneutrale fluglinie ist
ein schritt in die richtung auf jeden
fall auf jeden fragen sich anderen
fluglinien sich da mal ein beispiel
übernehmen
auf jeden fall
die weltklimakonferenz hat mich ziemlich
runter gezogen
die erde ist wahrscheinlich kaum noch zu
retten ich brauche jetzt erst mal was
zur aufmunterung einmal nach malle bitte
und damit zurück ins studio
[Applaus]